you can present yourself if you okay so
anyways our next speaker is Claudia you
know mm-hmm that he will talk about and
she will talk about search engines
bush nobody is it
perfect so bush so thanks her speaker so
thank you everybody for coming and I
will I'm going to talk about Bush it is
a search engine every um first I would
like to introduce myself my name is as
he said Claudia and my main background
it is not actually scientific I
harvested a law and Business
Administration and I have been working
at petit component is probably you
should know ecommerce for the last two
years at the beginning I was working at
the marketing department doing analytics
but for the last year I have been
leading the data science department and
more or less a year ago I received the
bread of improving the search engine of
artistic component this is more or less
how the outside the outside looks like
and to let you know how big this
challenge was this is the second most
visited page at our website it received
a hundred thousand citizens by day and
I'm sorry and if you are already a
customer of our side probably you will
know that there is another one a little
one sets as you type searcher and but it
is not developed by me it on behind of
that there's an SQL query so
the main library I used for developed
such as Dean was good goos means are so
made made by something that is moving
quickly and that's why that's what I was
trying to do move quick and develop fast
and thinking about my talk I I would
prefer to tittle the talk was so fast
and easy that even a lawyer as me
couldn't manage and I will tell you what
is worse as I said is a library that
allows you to build your own certain
Jane I think it is really fast it is
pull Python a does is um one of the main
resource reasons I choose it and also
you don't know to program in other
languages you know you don't need
compiler and nothing like dang no Java
behind allows you to fully customize the
parsing the certain function the scoring
algorithm and that's that was a thing
really important for me while I was
developing the desert desert but it has
some backpack drove all everything index
must be Unicode and also by now it is
not available at Python 3 I know that
some of you are probably actually asking
himself why I didn't choose a nice
t-shirt well a year ago I had no team I
was alone and I had to work isolated my
main focus as I said is the InDesign
search definition also we don't have we
we actually we don't have big data
because we we have more or less twelve
thousand products alive in our store
and as always I need to develop it fast
I'm only in a month because we sell said
before this one has a bounce rate about
20% and this was so bad for us so now a
year after probably my decision will be
different but I think it could be nice a
nice livery for someone who has need who
has to develop it fast quick and doesn't
have to index a lot of documents and I
think he's a neat and clean solution
while I was analyzing the project
I already define these 4+1 stages the
first one was the data treatment and I
will explain why this was very important
for me the slides will be available and
also the notebook github but you can try
to do it with the data set of a VA we'll
have at the client panel it is a CSV
format unfortunately everything is in
Layton it has a special status missing
values also I didn't had any tack in the
data base
there are a lot of emphasis and
irrelevant information mixed with the
relevant information that I needed so I
have to work a lot and have a lot of fun
in that month so those are the main
fields in the CSV the category provoked
the name not the long description but
you could screw screw it from our
website if you need it
and this is more or less how we look
like the skew the product SKU the name
that kind of of product information
so much one of the main tasks was to
refer that was to retrieve the text and
I use the tf-idf algorithm ache the task
this is the classical definition of the
algorithm and those are my main four
functions this is a very useful
algorithm
to retreat the relevant word in a corpus
but unfortunately the first time I run
this code in my database I didn't
retrieve very useful tax it is because
my college are putting in the
description words that there are
meaningless I mean fantastic great super
cute that's what the words I retrieve so
I have to made an extensive list of
adjectives the it is also bladed it's
more or less about five thousand words
and well it works but as I as I going to
say after it is a team work if you need
to develop certain gene and you are
working with someone corpus it is very
useful to speak with the people that are
eliminated that feed in your corpus
so in this snippet I am removing the
Spanish stop words also the English stop
words and the meaningless adjectives and
after that for functions you will
retrieve the tags
otherwise there other ideas you can
implement is to use your first version
certainty to retrieve another tax I
already have in my corpus in my
documents words like heat and baking and
something like that and I have to
to rephrase those words or find synonyms
a child or me knows on infantil things
like that and also you can use the
database as a target well actually in
our search engine of the smartphone's
below 150 attack us tip the second state
is to define the schema which has six
types of fields text for the
descriptions keyword for the tags ID for
the product I asked you
numeric and data that also could be used
as a table and boolean the field
boosting is passive useful when you have
fields that are more relevant than
others you can imagine that the name of
the product is more relevant that the
specification something stuff like that
you also have to be prepared to deal
with the form diversity goose has two
analyzers the stamen and variation both
are working rate in English but not so
good in Spanish that is always happening
with language libraries in Python
I already implemented the stamen because
it is removing the suffixes and it was
more or less but I'm not very happy with
that I could you could also program
yourself for diversity I dare you to kid
this is more or less how it works
we have analyzed and it is more stamina
to move in the suffixes and variations
is storing all the words form in the
index because of the process before of
retrieving the tags it is kind of a slow
process I already prepare a data set
with field tags
one of the steps you have to do is to
clean the corpus as I said everything
must be unicode and we have the database
in Layton and we have some special
characters and also HTML you have to
clean everything and that's the thing I
do in this I have made in this snippet
in the CSV we have almost 12,000
products and this is an example of the
schema the first field is the product
ESCO it is important to be store because
the website is going to retrieve it and
use it for the view
ian is the it's another reference of the
product category these in this step I'm
using the stamen analyzer with a mean
size of 3 characters and it's going to
be all sister but it is up to you the
article name it is also it has also the
same configuration and also I have put
in these for this field field boosting
it will duplicate the word scoring if
you are sorting the results by these but
the world scoring it will be first it
the world's hard in this field tags what
is a keyword I feel the price and stop
well once the schema is setting is set
up next step is to index which allows
you to create the index the first time
met Sigmund they let documents if they
are now not ever be able update
documents are made on incremental
indexing this is a simple indexing
function we are going to iterate through
our catalog add in each product to the
index
it was running on my old laptop so it
took 25 seconds but in in in in my
computer it is about 10 seconds for the
two thousand documents it outputs three
documents so what we do is to do all
these slow process in one server and
move after all move these three
documents to the production server which
is Halloween the the certain gene it
weighs about 10 minutes which is not the
last step is do the search process is
include it is including the parsing the
scouring sorting the result filter and
paging about the scoring by default it
is using BM 25 F but you can change it
by the one I was mentioned before tf-idf
also let you Peyton we are using these
for retrieving the categories I'm
printing on the west side in the left
panel
a novel spread person by default
decision parser personal query is to
compare the string type by the user in
an in a query object by default it is
using one word in one field of the
schema but it is also available a multi
field parser and this is what we are
using absolutely as I said it is fully
customizable if you are able to program
your own parcel or you want to make some
changes in the classes you cool it is
dissipate open and the code personalizes
here's an example the user types Cargill
or Dakota goes away and we are cleaning
that string about with Star Wars in
Spanish TT ninjas make it lower and we
are converting in in a purse query I
would like to to mark that we are using
here and our group in the parameter in
the multi-person function we are using
group or group if you avoid this the day
it will be using every word and set a
product that contains every word type by
the user
this is an example of our search
function it will retrieve more than 800
heat and this is the best one don't
incur a loss also you would like to
change the shorten as a sample if you
have short in your sector like or a
filter in the user who could sort by
relevance our price so until I die we
are receiving that parameter uncertain
the result here here you can see a
comparison between the default sorting
which is the word scoring and also by
the price yeah filtering well you can
filter in a positive and also in a
negative way actually we are while you
are typing in our certainty you are
making 2 calls to our search one for
retrieving the heat and one for
retrieving the categories and if you
mark one of those categories they will
filter your previous query and
retrieving the result other stuff well
actually it was in production in in
October of last year
initially running in flasks but then
calming the Black Friday and everything
crash and we have to we had to put
tornado recently while I was making the
talk I discovered that there's a package
with flash rouge and SQL ultimate what
is very fast and also it could reduce
some time save you some time
we are also studying the navigation
events and also the search Hammond in
MongoDB and we are planning to use that
that information for make the related
search with the Association algorithms
our qualities are programming the levels
did you mean with the Levenstein design
distance as Manuel mentioned yesterday
and we are planning to move this big one
or this real search engine to the little
one but we are waiting for our new
website that's why actually we are doing
a/b testing and since changing the
algorithms with by week so if you found
something strange in our certain team
please send me a message and we will fix
it because one thing I learned with this
project is that make a certain sign is
not really easy it is a difficult thing
Google knows it and you have to be
prepared to a lot of hot fixes something
that don't appear or something strange
and it is a team working thing I had to
speak a lot with the CEO Department the
catalog and department doing Peleg
illogical staff and trying to make them
understand that is difficult to find
something that there's no
in our corpus I cannot find infantil if
it's not in the corpus and people are
typing that kind of things and they have
to put the words in the documents and
also one thing I learned with this
project with this process it is better
to work with a team that allows you when
I move from marketing to the IT
department it was quite difficult to
work with my qualities because they are
working in PHP and I was the only one
working in Python and this was the first
project in Python in the company and it
was quite difficult to talk about and
I'm putting in production so that's why
I really like woosh because it helps me
in this process it was neat easy
customers able and helps me a lot so I
think it was so fast and I'm sorry
because of that so you can make a lot of
questions and hope I can answer but
first and applause please
so questions hello thank you for your
speech it's very interesting topic my
question is you talked about steaming
and you say that estimate quite easy in
English yeah but you talk so we tell
about the Spanish so you could do some
steaming actually I am working with a
steaming model in with use it is not so
good but this is working so that I was
doing some research about foreign
diversity in Spanish and I was not able
to find any library that is working with
lemon limit ization or something like
that
there's some website I could send you
after the talk that but there's no API
so you can test it but anything more it
is quite difficult to work in Spanish so
I opted to cut the words and hope that
everything is ok well first of all
thanks for the talk it was super
interesting and I was wondering when you
are using the sorting sorting results
kind of sort based on any feature any
field that is not like a text like this
or tablished fields are dates and
numeric you can see we are using it with
relevance with word scoring and you can
also use it by the to put it the newest
products at the beginning and that kind
of stuff very interesting talk thank you
I mean you said that you was able to
convince your colleagues to change
languages from PHP to Python
I think many people here would be
interested was right the big change or
you are still in the process well it is
going to be record yes so to say the
truth when I was moved from marketing to
IT and consider my background that is
not scientific that was not so easy so
my main instruction is to work without
this to be my qualities please do not
disturb anyone so that's what they and
be quiet so I was trying to find
something that was easy for me and a
month pass and then they found that it
was everything done and they have no
other way to put it in production and
that's what happened
so it is better to trash yourself make
the staff work silently and after all
when everything is done so you have to
put it on put it is working so actually
it was a success because we had a sister
as I said we had a 20% bounce rate in
the shed inside which is a really big
problem in an e-commerce because the
people was not able to find by the they
were looking for so we change it we
double the visits with reduce the bones
until the no and it is really nice so it
was difficult we put it in an API I did
don't have to worry about the certain
time function and they are working in
the staff and I'm working on mine and
this is excellent advice for other
people trying to convince colleagues to
change to change languages to make
everything work and then it's so it's a
bit next time thank you
should I question you say there was a
slight way to say that goodbye sorry I'm
here I will you say that perhaps you
have to do this again you might want to
choose the last exert it was something
like that but I wonder if you know which
are things from elasticsearch that we
will like if this already does a lot of
things and it's Python and you have to
compile anything and it's much easier
why would you use the last sentence I
mentioned that because whose it is going
to be as lowered when you have more and
more documents nowadays it is controlled
because we have 2000 references and
hopefully we have some more next year
but no more than third 30,000 so I could
manage it with us but in the future I
don't know maybe it is better to choose
another Escalade volt solution that's
why I mentioned the last assert and I
suppose that you are programmers we have
a level and I sell that will be a
question obvious in the in the audience
so that's why I put that slide now my
situation is different I have a great
team for work and have a help in the
system Department so it could be better
to choose another Excalibur from Shaban
and all the time I made this decision
was for healthy for me